in one cross test  scp-682 the hard-to-destroy reptile was  made to face off against  scp-1361 a giant aggressive mass of  animal slurry that envelops and digests  everything it touches before briefly  taking on their traits just over 1 000  kilograms of  scp-1361 was poured onto scp-682  and it successfully enveloped the  creature the problem was that it then  began taking on traits and a temperament  incredibly similar to scp-682  after developing legs jaws and other  physical features similar to the reptile  it broke out of containment and killed  17 members of staff after several failed  attempts to stop the creature with small  arms fire it was finally destroyed by  the aerial deployment of napalm 682  skeletal carcass was retrieved from  within and placed back in its chamber it  had regenerated back to perfect health  within a mere six hours